Nói chào con cười tung cả tăng quốc đưa lục tung tăng quốc leo thần tóc một bằng xếp hàng át sọ,
quay trở lại với bản áp đích mới nhất lục tung tăng quốc đã gây sốt khi người chơi kéo nhau đang nhập ngay sơ vơ.
Rốt cộng đồng nủ yếu đã liên tục và ai cũng phải nhất địa con tưởng chú lục nà chà mà đồng giang thế.
Nghe nơi quốc hơi chơi bởi mỗi cú func thương của nà chà khu chỉ là đòn tấn công.
Mà còn đang họn lửa định mẹc.
Đó sẽ tuyến phòng tụi của đối phương, sau vơ mỗi mở chiều kì vụ đã khu ngươi sếp hàng tinh năng nà chà vừa ra mắt đá khiến tổn kỏi tăng quốc dùng chuyển tưởng nào và cú fun nhé.
Tất cả đưa cái tên lục tung tăng quốc leo thần tóc một bằng xếp hàng hêm free,
bột mặt hàng là tóc tính cùng tỷ lại, đừng đứng ngoài cựb bảo lối nhất là người chiến thích mua này.
Tại gây này, phá đảo về bài.
Hãy gây được tùng tóc bức tài hươi cây và áp tổn.
Đưa gây hát lắm, đưa trả trụ, lúc công, trong viên.